شحد خائري لدى الترسانه العسكريه
الامريكيه يدفع واشنطن للاستعانه بذخائر
كوريا الجنوبيه كي تتمكن من الاستمرار في
دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا في حربها مع روسيا
صفقه سريه تم الاتفاق عليها مبدئيا بين
طرفين لبيع قذائف مدفعيه موجهه لصالح
القوات الاوكرانيه حسب ما افادت صحيفه
ولستريد جورنال الصحيفه نقلت عن مسؤولين
امريكيين وصفتهم بالمطالعين ان الولايات
المتحده ستشتري مئه الف طلقه من ذخيره
المدفعيه عيار
155 ملم كما ترفع الصفقه الموجهه الحرجه
عن صول الممتنع عن تقديم دعم عسكري الى
اوكرانيا لكن اثرها الاهم هو في تخفيف
الضغط على المخزون الامريكي من قذائف
المدفعيه الذي انخفضه الى مستويات تثير
قلق البنت تكون المساعدات العسكريه هذه
سبقتها معونات تجاوزت خيارات من الدولارات
ففي منتصف اكتوبر الماضي كشف مسؤولون
امريكيون عن حزمه مساعدات لاوكرانيا بقيمه
757 مليون دولار
سبقتها في سبتمبر مساعدات عسكريه بقيمه
مليار ومئه مليون دولار لتصل حزمه
المساعدات الامريكيه لكيف منذ بدايه الحرب
الى 18 مليارا و600 مليون دولار وفقه
تقارير امريكيه
لكن يبدو انني ران الحرب التهمت تلك
المليارات فلا تزال اوكرانيا تطالب
بالمزيد رغم ما ترسله اوروبا ايضا وتمتده
مشكله الذخائر الى اوروبا التي تعاني هي
الاخرى من نقص كبير لذا تتفاوض المانيا
احد اكبر الداعمين لكيف مع دول في شرق
وجنوب اوروبا لتقديم معدات عسكريه
لاوكرانيا في مقابل اسلحه المانيه احدث
حنان المصري العربيه